on sent vraiment une ville qui est qui
concentré je dirais alors c'est vrai
qu'ici c'est relativement calme hein ça
fait deux jours que l'on entend presque
pas de de sirènes d'alerté mais ce n'est
pas pour autant que la ville ne continue
pas de se préparer à ces méthodiquement
alors vous avez bien sûr les soldats qui
renforce les défenses et puis vous avez
les habitants beaucoup d'habitants qui
qui est chacun comme ils peuvent à on
voit des habitants qui le matin vont
porter des colis alimentaires vont faire
des courses les porter dans des locaux
pour qu'ensuite et bien elle ces colis
soit acheminé sur le front sur les
positions des soldats on voit des
habitants qui vont sur la plage
collecter du sable pour ensuite les
mettre dans des sacs on voit des chaînes
humaines de gens qui portent des sacs de
sable pour encore une fois fortifier les
défenses les défenses de la ville il y a
eu cette image hier un petit peu ce
symbole de la statue du duc de richelieu
qui vous savez l'un des des fondateurs
de la ville d'odessa qui a été renforcée
sur toute la hauteur par des sacs de
sable donc une ville très concentré on
dit souvent codesa c'est là la plus
russe des villes ukrainiennes mais c'est
en réalité une ville qui n'aime pas du
tout qu'on lui dicte sa conduite et
c'est pour cela qu'elle est aussi bien
décidé à ceux à ceux à se défendre